(happy music)
- [Speaker] In real life,
they could pass a new law
which actually might happen.
If you've been following the news, okay,
so, major budget problems, all along.
But in 2011 there was...
- I want you to think about
the programs, what does it
mean to cut these programs,
what does it look like?
- There were about 19 million veterans
in the US in 2015.
- I know that the
transportation could obviously
be improved, and what everyone
has said is completely true.
But I don't know if it's worth
adding, putting it up there.
- We might just need to reallocate it.
Because maybe it's not
being used properly or
can be, being used better.
I thought it was gonna be
much easier, definitely.
I thought, it was gonna be something that
we could all work out.
I thought people would share my beliefs.
Obviously. People had different beliefs.
In the news, I read a lot
about how certain things
that the government does is ineffective
and not working, so I
thought that it would be
easy to take away those things
that might not be working
for people, or reallocating funds.
And I realized that just, monetarily,
that didn't really work out.
When you hear 10 billion
dollars cut, you're, okay,
10 billion dollars cut, but
then when you realize that
certain amount of people are
gonna lose health insurance,
or won't have access to
clean water for example
and just seeing that
manifest in chip form was
really frightening.
- I do think you know, the
lower end of categories
like energy and agriculture
need more chips.
I came in thinking that,
you know, of course we were
gonna learn important things
but it was gonna be boring
and it wasn't gonna be
a lot of fact based.
Which was the opposite
of what I think now.
When you're cutting from a category
and you don't necessarily get
the funding from that category
you don't think that
it will have, you know,
a drastic effect on
the nation but it will.
- Quarter billion.
- And I think you should
change your mind set
and what you define as boring.
Because a lot of these
categories effect us,
on a day to day basis and we don't know.
- [Daniel] Can I ask a question?
- You sure can.
- [Daniel] Okay
- You know, everyone was in their bubble,
and they come together and
they're hearing, points
of view that they don't generally
hear in their daily lives.
- We took 10 billion out of
the 44 2 point billion dollars
in highways and our justification
is that it's pretty much
that there's more important
topics to be spending on.
- Okay, highways, don't
worry about the potholes,
don't worry about the
bridges falling down.
There are more important things.
- So by pushing them, they're
beginning to see, okay,
it's not just oh we're gonna
cut from conservation efforts.
What does it mean if there
are streams that are being
polluted near someone's home.
- And that we don't really
need to make more aircraft,
when there's nothing wrong
with the ones we have now.
- [Nina] That's to federally
subsidize healthcare.
- If you do this, it's gonna
hurt these people in this way
and these people in these way,
and that there are
people behind the numbers
and that that's really
important to consider.
(happy music)